no voy a aumentar los impuestos quiero
que bajen no voy a aumentar la deuda
quiero empezar a pagarla en este próximo
mandato si me dan la confianza y
solamente hay una manera de financiar
este trabajar progresivamente más con un
eje que es el pleno empleo porque el
trabajo para mí es algo necesario como
lo logramos hacer y un segundo pilar que
es llevar la edad legal que es de 62
años por cuatro meses por año es decir
en el 2000 el 28 llegarán a los 65 en
yo propuse una cláusula de revisión pero
tomando en cuenta varios dispositivos el
primero es la carrera larga hay que
mantenerlo y se tiene razón el segundo
es la dificultad del trabajo usted
quiere acabar con este sistema y creo
que es una mala idea porque hay personas
como nosotros nosotros cuatro
subjetivamente
trabajaremos incluso más allá de los 65
si creo a todos aquellos que están en
nuestro sector entonces se necesita
libertad hay que poder proteger aquellos
que tienen más trabajos muy difíciles
para que se puedan jubilar antes
no señora depende porque la edad legal
permite justamente no volver sobre estos
temas pero usted no es justa porque como
usted no toma en cuenta los criterios de
dificultad del empleo no sé alguien qué
comenzar los 25 años terminan los 67 en
este
esto los criterios de dificultad del
empleo permiten ser justos los criterios
de dificultad del empleo para los
obreros agrícolas para los compatriotas
que trabajan
matando
reses
y hay que suprimir estos regímenes
especiales y aquellos que a las personas
que contratan en estos sitios como el
atp pdf entonces ya no deben ser
entrar en el sistema
especial sino en el general porque usted
no quiere explicar cómo va a financiar
esos progresos usted no es honesta con
la gente yo le estoy explicando no es
agradable para hacerse elegir es más
fácil decir que volvemos con una reforma
anterior pero usted vuelve sobre un
sistema que ya no está equilibrio